[Musique]
c'était un village offre un tournevis
bravo c'est un défaut labonté et d une
injure samaras
ouais c'est un caveau au rebond assez
diack
et c'était d une cicatrice
un bleu à l'âme c'était un dictateur mi
temps c'était une injure or une rigolote
qui aurait peut-être de ne pas dit une
maladie je parle par kingson ou un truc
comme ça et quand même un microbe
or une grippe une grille quelconque ce
pas un peu de champagne dans le noir
est-il un reptile un serpent à lunettes
pourquoi poser lunettes n'atteint pas
les arbres en noir ou blanc c'est comme
si terry une infirmité
c'est dur je sais pas aveugle va
peut-être muet si tu étais un assassin
du srec qui comme assassin jack
l'éventreur on en parle encore un vice
la vertu une guerre
un petit conflit de rien du tout il sait
dans entre deux tribus africaines un
supplice on en a plus inventer que deux
positions pour baiser quand celle
difficile le choix
alors je dirais la roue peut-être c'est
atroce de poids c'est la pire celle dont
vous laisse apparaître les quoi c'est
quand on suspend le mec au dessus d'une
corde
j'ai pas dit m et puis on laisse tomber
la corde alors ils tombent au sol et on
remonte et on laisse tomber indéfiniment
ce que fait nicolas hulot tous les
samedis dans ushuaïa quoi au menu ce
point élasticité guerre mondiale c'est
pour ça un accident
l'accord de 4 un accident ces poids de
la route
un quotidien et si tu étais une
cicatrice elle sait où ouais sous
l'aisselle gauche
probablement elle ne voit pas fait nous
sort que sa cicatrice ya pas besoin de
frimer avec les plus belles sont
intérieures ouais ça fait un peu
prétentieux bien faire mais je crois que
tout le monde en est plein mais on ne
doit pas tout
[Musique]
je te dis si tu étais un défaut du srec
elle défaut la différence si tu étais
une injure
[Musique]
allez vous faire si tu étais une maladie
pire que le sida est ce possible oui
d'ailleurs au fait c'est parce que c'est
à cause du sida tu crois qu'elle se
refuse à lui
rennes de l'homme sait bien qu'il ya une
sorte de peur je dire ah ouais à qui
redistribue tout les cas ouais et que ça
va être très intéressant pour les vrais
professionnels de jouer de cette paire
ambiance si des demandes des vampires
nouveau son talent s'il était un microbe
celui de la nuit un insecte 1,5 scarabée
immortel un reptile
là le serpent de la genèse c'était un
vis à vis ouais on la notion même de vie
si c'était un supplice un supplice a
toujours la chose privée qu'il se serait
bon à laquelle personne a subi son
quelle personne de rédaction un supplice
un ultime supplice moral moral c'était
un supplice tu seras un support à la
supplique morale qui va à présent former
son un accident la visite dans
la vie est un accident si tu étais un
défaut du srec elle défie mangeurs de
gâteaux il cite étaient une injure
charognards s'il était une maladie
isolement
c'était un insecte
sreg mousse pourquoi
parce que des mouches pas empêché de
travailler quand j'écrivais que les
mouches son opiniâtre reviennent
toujours se mettent à l'infernal là où
il faut pas c'est infernal
une motion nous vous empêche de faire la
sieste une mouche peut tomber ses stars
un livre si tu étais un assassin je
serai soit bernard henri lévy soit
philippe soler soit jean edern hallier
je tuerai l'esprit cet été une arme je
serai une arme blanche très aiguisé
comme les crayons je taime crayon tous
les soirs avant d'aller me coucher ça
m'étonne pas
si tu étais un poison je serai critique
littéraire est un collabo
je serai français tu vois qu'il est bien
ce jeu et si tu étais un supplice du
srec elle supplie cible je serai
directeur de rubrique littéraire dans un
grand magasin est situé d un accident
pour finir je continuerai
[Musique]
si tu étais une injure une injure allez
vous faire [ __ ]
c'est la même que sollers exactement
pareil c'était un microbe c'est pas
l'arrivisme site était un poison le
cyanure pour un suicidaire comme moi
c'est un projet un collabo 3 bat et
rebâti car j'admire beaucoup les deux
étendards quittant descend d'un des plus
grands romans français du xxème siècle
un dictateur néron nero pourtant tu
connais bien les philippines qui avaient
le passé du temps j'arrivais à trop
filer dans les tribunes de mal à marcos
mais marcos n'ait pas été un pas dicter
la norme au repos c'était un très bon
démocrate marcoux c'est un grand
calomnie et 10 pas bon moi je regrette
marcos
c'était un homme extrêmement les mêmes
lacunes et aussi qu'il fallait quelqu'un
de charmant et marcos avait un peu plus
de branches ouais marco c'était un n'est
pas si mauvais que la ville dès que les
gens qui en parlent de la remise du mal
marcos marcos mais marcos naf
indicateurs ne majorait cette année on
est tellement vrai dictateur dictateur
c'était un avis
je dirais le vent et vi pour moi ça
c'est l'abstinence ou alors on pourrait
dire l'ivrognerie parce que j'adore le
bon vin
alors est ce qu'on peut
et c'est la lumière s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
cette année cette lumière c'est vrai bon
je pose la question aux deux on va rater
la plus rapide des deux d'accord vous
avez un portrait chinois si tu étais une
fleur qu'est-ce que tu serais qu'est-ce
que tu serais si tu étais une fleur toi
un mieux au tice à cause de ses yeux je
sais pas c'est une seule main une rose
une roue si j'étais une fleur une
marguerite chirac au sol pour patrick
aujourd'hui non pas son procès par non
pas la coiffure la ligne blanche est un
peu déçu on a dit prédit pas le physique
pas les cheveux pas les parents sauf que
moi je parle pas de fleurs j'ai dit si
tu étais un [ __ ] du swing et comme
[ __ ] le salon d'agriculture
merci mais les êtres été incités à un
défaut olivier wii mote ya cabrio et si
vous étiez une injure vous soyez quoi
comme un sur moi j'aime bien petite
crotte
oui moi je dis non seulement sa mère de
fela car si vous étiez une maladie une
sérié quoi comme maladie
l'ange une blanche mais oui c'est bien
là j'ai rejoins moi je vais les couleurs
pour la couleur un accident à coacher
patrick sébastien sanchez semble pas
jouer les coucous remake des trucs
dessus pour laisser tu t'imagines sommet
d'hier a passé sa vie à taper sa tête
sur les bois je suis franchement très
sûr le porte chez nos appels
on m'a dit reste concentré si vous étiez
une perversion alors très très bien
justement j'étais une perversion moi je
veux dire vrai si on était une formation
si vous étiez une guerre la guerre de
cent ans je pense y est ça a duré
longtemps
c'était trop long on n'est pas le monde
garde briquet pour les cyclopes arrêt à
l'enfer moi j'ai pas tous les jours un
dictateur le coiffeur de patrick
sébastien
[Applaudissements]
on a eu du vent et que tu vois plus
alors si vous étiez un bis si vous étiez
un vis à vis à vis ça c'est bien
non non non service 5 et 4 e olivier je
suis avec olivier morel qui a redit moi
je sais plus je suis leur aile
ok si vous étes est un supplice supplice
être obligé de regarder patrick
sébastien savez les cheveux sur un filon
là alors réussir à faire parler de soi
quand c'est d'autres invités ont eu tôt
fait de la pub si vous étiez un poison à
rat la turbine lazare dit vas-y vas-y
étiez vous étiez une infirmité la
coiffure hors du temps qui ne connaît
bien tagro il m'a dit la coiffure moi je
veux non mais moi je souhaite et je le
dis je le dis aux millions de gens qui
nous regardent
écrivez-nous soussan marotte quoi bon
dire que patrick gardes sache je lui
dois garder toute façon mais oui pour
moi ça sera sympa ta crinière de lion
c'est joli c'est joli ça j'avais plus
politique ça me faisait au moins deux
queues de cheval
c'était plutôt un soutien à sa balle à
lutter le coiffeur a pris si vous étiez
une humiliation
il va bien sûr continuer moi ça me gêne
pas le bouc de patrick sébastien c'est
bien et si vous étiez un animateur tv
mais voilà après losique un patrick
sébastien patois compter les minutes
pour patrick sabatier
oui et bouger
[Musique]
je fais bonsoir pas créé que j'en ai vu
des pires depuis
oui c'est ce que j'allais dire la jolie
et non pas pourquoi il n'est pas patrick
savatier lettre non merci j'ai dit à
mathieu vivaldi j'aurais dit linda hardy
comme ça j'aurais pu me regarder dans
une glace à poil et me touche et des
méchants est pas idiot nantes a raison
car c'est le bon bout mais moi je lui
disais cap addiction attention linda
vous les connaissez déjà linda scolaire
on s'est croisé mon chemin je
patienterai ont bien mené
tu te souviens que paris n'avait pas
ligne à cette époque là
je suis comme ça les méchants du nord et
cherche à un mètre et à terville ça vous
restez avec nous non oui vraiment un
grand plaisir
restez beaux restes et tous phares
allumés les linéaires s'il vous plaît je
sais pas
[Musique]
vous connaissez le portrait chinois non
je fais une femme voici le portrait
chinois c'est un jeu qui est vieux comme
on dit si vous étiez une fleur alors dit
surin myosotis tous les lentilles porter
chinois c'est autre chose
ah bon celle inverse totalement finie si
vous étiez un défaut vous seriez quoi
comme des faux argent chez rien encore
mieux vous aller me reposer après
justine maladie enfin je serai la
coqueluche fut rien si vous étiez un
accident circulation si vous étiez une
perversion la pire vite y ait une guerre
en dentelle un dictateur papy nash est
une arme de pacotille un supplice
chinois une cicatrice d'amour si j'ai
tjrs en assassin landru parce qu'il
aimait les femmes soutient un [ __ ]
vous pas mal non
[Musique]
c'est un nazi fait quoi comme l'a dit
elle est belle la vie sinon j'aurais dit
encore 1,8 de moins
c'est une infirmité
[Musique]
je me disais c'est quoi la vérité vérité
joie m
je suis déjà venu vous voir l'espèce
super eagles et bien résister été un
poison 6,6 du tout de suite tu penses à
ça des fois non
[Musique]
ah bon ça
pas trop ah bon j'ai pas à aller oui oui
le seule arme que tu as chez toi c'est
une sorte quoi et comme tu la mets sur
la table on pense pas que tu conserves
vraiment dans certains jeux c'est m'a
été donnée par le père des calices la
dernière seuls les officiers blessés
avaient droit à cette seringue en poule
2 entier et deviennent pompiers de la
loire eagles ou frankel
c'est vraiment fou et briquet à s'étoffe
tout ça ouais perfide albion est un
accident vous était arrivé bien le
hindenburg là le truc nazis qui s'est
scratché sur new york et du rap avant la
venue des sites étaient une cicatrice et
un tiers
je suis quand même
pourquoi
[Musique]
deux lâchers pour y arriver
avec les grands et jackie
mais dans le métier
j'étais moche quand même ouais
maintenant j'ai eu et c'est beaucoup de
blé de l'orge la bêtise écouté beaucoup
de blé il est parfois je suis au jeu non
c'est une avancée mais un des derniers
grands chefs
schirmeck du 19 octobre dans les hôtels
ou encore voir les jets privés
c'était bien mais finalement ça j'ai pas
fini
oui encore quelques bons coups
avec bambou ya une marée avec lui deux
claques dans ailleurs les pesages joris
et fait un shampoing ils sont réellement
combien le fils de son père y en a
[Musique]
si tu étais un défaut tu serais quoi
j'étais un défaut ouais l'envi une envie
d'aller assouvi un peu ton envie là ça
va non pas encore je vais très très star
une injure s'ajuste quoi est capable
tu es incapable d'un sur six mouvements
en algérie celle de nietzsche qui sait
donner à l'autre la honte de soi c'est
la pire chose qu'il fait des fois quand
tu servait à saint tropez d'aller honte
de toi de ces sacs pour ça que tu leur
emploi et barclays et nettoyer ses
chemises tachées à la mousse au chocolat
s'interrompt puis je compense la prime
si les 10 sec c'est important
c'était une infirmité
j'étais une infirmité votre incapable
d'aimer c'est sûr
un assassin si j'étais un assaut sens
peut-être landru parce qu'il aimait
roman les femmes et une guerre j'étais
une guerre les guerre des chefs la
guerre les sexes prix
je passe bien quoi maintenant
c'est toujours et ces filles qui
s'appelle marine kit équilibre tu vas
rester longtemps duquel tu es petit à
petit nous tu as trouvé ton chez toi tu
as trouvé ton perdu d'approuver mari ça
va s'arranger si tu étais une arme à
double tranchant
[Musique]
tu serais une maladie un cancer
quand un bon concert la généralise les
grecs mais encore que le pari est des
régions français qui avait une façon de
faire la sécurité sociale à la carte
on parie sur deux camps on mourra ici on
gagne on est remboursé le triple le loto
ça peut rapporter gros
le cancer on ne sait jamais il ya une
maladie cardiovasculaire vous le pensez
voilà les branchés incident ait pas une
formule est donc non mais y en a
d'autres actions voiture étant une
troisième
donc tu paries récupérait en fonction de
ce que tu as décidé plus ou moins cher
et les autres frais remboursés mais
aussi d'un truc qui est à notre sens un
cancer et si tu étais un microbe
c'est un petit micro d'eric raoult
petits microbes un champignon une truffe
invite si tu étais un vis à vis la
masturbation spectateurs
c'est ce que tu préfères et c'est ce qui
reste ouais tout le monde s'en va
cet été une guerre une guerre non un
mouvement un mouvement
guerrier ou en soutenant la révolte du
ghetto de varsovie je trouve assez
qu'ils allaient s'en vient oui le seul
truc
enfin chaque fois que les civils casse
la gueule aux militaires dit varsovie
tempère oui oui mais cela dit ça n'a
rien à voir si simplement que j'aime pas
trop les militaires un accident un
accident
ouais pas une essence très bon dans la
course une cicatrice non je dirais pas
et d'albert vous voulez la voir et une
ba alors si comme âgées elles sont lents
toutes façons de faire mes fesses tout
enfin les chapeauter les fentes les
sites était un terroriste pour finir par
un terroriste enfin bon je suis pas un
terroriste pas du tout non je ne vois
pas comment c'est la merde quand même
non non je fous la merde foutent la
merde dans la dans le fumier la miellée
frêche
non non je suis pas un théoricien alors
on va passer maintenant à l'anti
portrait chinois d'état à attention
pareil voire pascal bruckner de laisser
le portrait chinois dans un terreau
lentilles portrait chinois du ventre et
chinois en vie si vous étiez une fleur
sur à myosotis et ses lentilles portrait
chinoise c'est négatif
donc si vous étiez un défaut sur
lesquels défaut l'égoïsme une injure
sympa une maladie le tétanos un accident
un crash d'avion une perversion les
câlins une guerre à dieffenthal une
guerre la guerre des boutons
un microbe la peste un vice le sucre un
dictateur amin dada une arme le fil
dentaire un supplice l'écartèlement une
cicatrice
les bleus à l'âme un poison
poison
un poison curare un [ __ ] dieu le père
un assassin gilles de rais une torture
les caresses une humiliation être
ignorée
[Musique]
parfait alors donc vous connaissez le
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
fleur je serai un museau this ça c'est
lent et sport très chic ou une rose
c'est pas ça du tout justement c'est si
vous étiez un défaut je serais très très
sympa et un petit peu chiante
je suis utile l'injure va te faire cuire
un oeuf pourri et mange le mal est venue
la pestouille à un accident je serai
deux autos tamponneuses qui se rentrent
dedans une perversion écoutez ce qui ne
me regarde pas une guerre je serai la
guerre des strings parce que je voudrais
ouvrir une guerre je suis contre les
strings à bord faisait pour les temps
gabriel tang ah non je vais faire les
bons grosse leipp
[Rires]
je vous explique pas ce que j'ai j'ai
mené une croisade il ya cinq ans contre
lesquels sont vous savez c'était ces
gens de collants avec le pied coupé et
beaucoup de femmes qui les portait donc
j'étais à devenu un peu la chef anti
qu'elles sont enfin bon maintenant c'est
les strings qu'on voit de plus en plus
avec les beaux jours et je trouve ça un
peu curieux parce que le principe du
string c'est quand même que ça ne se
voit pas or ça se voit que j'ai sur le
contre vous le tanga non plus non le
tanga nous est un gars string ou tripous
que cela et pour bon style ipad d'apple
le string parce que j'en suis resté à
une définition que carlos a donné
récemment aux grosses têtes dit j'aime
bien le string parce que ça permet aux
chats de jouer avec affichage il y avait
un dessin de wismes un affreux pas vu
c'est une femme sur la plage couché sur
le ventre
il y avait un homme derrière elle avec
david coupé en deux dans le sens de la
longueur et elle lui elle se retourna
eût dit si tu avais un peu plus patiente
[Rires]
on continue nam de doha coupe faim parce
qu'après on n'a plus faim du tout un
supplice bad obliger tout le monde à
mettre des strings vous aussi moi aussi
moi c'est pas moi je porte pas de slip
voilà autant ne pas en mettre du tout
voilà moi je jouis de suite j'ai rien
autant rispat à vous le dire j'ai
philippe le sait vous gagnez du temps je
m'habille toujours pareil je vais pas de
ce livre et j'ai vite habillez vous
étiez un poison
je serai une poison déjà tu peux si vous
êtes une [ __ ]
alors j'aime pas du tout ce mot parce
que je trouve ça un mot qu'on emploie
quand enfin les hommes emploi quand ils
sont un peu à cours d'idées alors qu'un
salon on dise l'ado a sonné c'était
mignon [ __ ] c'est que c'est un
compliment pour les hommes
ah bon ah oui ben je prends pas comme ça
oui philippe sierra léonais je vais plus
loin de vous c'est un brevet de
qualification
donc tendue et une pige à l'infini
c'est dexter faulk fring dessus tout ça
sans trophée bon je vous étiez un
assassin j'habiterai 21 oui c'est normal
une torture torture chassé par cette
sortie vous seriez une interview de
thierry ardisson
en résumé vous étiez une humiliation
c'est une infirmité à une infirmité ghg
une infirmité
oui c'est que j'ai un bras plus long que
l'autre regardez eh ben c'est pas drôle
tous les jours au jour le jour
et quand même une grosse différence et
pour applaudir c'est pénible c'est pas
possible de l'opep applaudir non je peux
pas voilà j'ai un mois puis le code
c'est toujours le même d'ailleurs qui
donc ça y est le même ça change par non
mais c'est vrai en berry ses volets et
pièces qui vous gêne le plus celui qui
est le plus long jeu le gameplay plus
court
[Rires]
les mots ne conçoivent pas du tout moi
je me bats pas je compatis m gratter à
deux niveaux différents
je suis désolé mais cette fois
[Musique]
l'écran
et finit en valais
et à dix on bouge pas pendant le kindle
comme réponse de thierry ardisson
vient alors le portrait chinois c'est si
c'était une fleur je serai à mieux
autistes lentilles portrait chinois
celle inverse
si vous étiez un défaut je serai la plus
grande qualité de mon pire ennemi
ouais pas mal ça vous étiez une rupture
je ne peux pas être une rupture j'ai
trop vécu j'ai pas envie d'en devenir
une injure si j'étais une injure je
serai fille de [ __ ] parce que je suis
pour la parité une maladie si j'étais
une maladie je crois que serait la
maladie d'alzheimer parce que je ne
pourrais pas me souvenir j'ai la maladie
d'alzheimer
un accident de concorde comme ça je fais
la une de tous les journaux dans le
monde entier pendant un mois une
perversion une perversion ça c'est
difficile je crois que je serai la
zoophilie parce que j'ai jamais
rencontré une tortue d'eau ou un cochon
d'inde ne refusait à 69 une guerre une
guerre dans une guerre lubrique c'est à
dire une guerre de position un vice
si j'étais un vice ben je serai un vice
qui englobe tous les autres vices et le
sexe parce que c'est en même temps un
jeu de hasard est une drogue
une trahison j'étais une trahison très
vite je suis déjà une imposture jeu peut
en plus être une trahison une arme une
arme
si j'étais une arme attendez laissez moi
un peu et une arme
si j'étais une arme je crois que serait
la culture parce que quand j'entends le
mot revolver je sens ma culture très
bien un supplice le supplice de la
baignoire parce que j'ai envie de mourir
proprement une cicatrice une cicatrice
le nombril du monde un poison et un
poison
bah alors là un poison qui coulerait
dans les veines de georges de boudu
bouche un [ __ ] c'est un [ __ ] serait
un gros [ __ ] comme ça je pourrais
sortir une grosse [ __ ] je suis et y
est une [ __ ] jeté une [ __ ] sur une
cape une fille capable de coucher avec
elle moix ouais un impôt un impôt sur le
sex-appeal comme ça je serai exonéré
ouais une panne bas une panne
d'inspiration qui frapperait tous les
écrivains qui écrivent plus vite que moi
un dictateur by clair il a écrit des
best-sellers investi l'air moi j'ai pas
réussi une infirmité une infirmité
michel petrucciani parce que j'adore le
jazz la nasa
guy debord parce qu'il a assassiné guy
debord un microbe
ah non ça me rendrait malade d'être un
microbe une plaie
j'étais une plaie je serai ouvertes
toute la nuit un fléau le sida parce que
je suis très people un terroriste je
serai un terroriste écoutez je préfère
sauter des bombes que les faire sauter
pas mal une torture une torture je serai
l'avenir parce que l'avenir appartient à
ceux qui se lèvent tôt et ça c'est une
torture et ce veto une humiliation une
humiliation une humiliation
je crois que je serai une soirée avec
rocco siffredi dans une boîte échangiste
est mort celle des autres
[Musique]
si tu étais une injure je rappelle pour
les jeux d'été une maladie concerne la
gorge offrir des prêts dégueulasse
parler bien partir et si tu étais un
vice sujet tournevis heures
brocheray td cette élection est une arme
je rappeler en quoi le fleuve s'est
jamais tué quelqu'un jusqu'à maintenant
tu le ferais bon ben si tu re plonger
bien un jour je sais pas il ya un mec je
vous le demande
j'aurais pu le faire donc j'étais était
vraiment accro torre quelqu'un puisse
faire pour pas grand chose pour pas
grand chose
un poison chimique
d'ailleurs l'alhambra à paris beaucoup
des recettes vous ça le loader
rai 2 0 mais ce n'est pas de rechercher
un supplice du pal
et si tu étais un accident quelque chose
très violent crash en avant après
l'explosion alerte un flash une overdose
[Musique]
c'est un défaut par exemple j'étais un
défaut - un torrent d'injures et rodez
j'étais bien à sa fin j'étais un
important
mais l'esprit pourquoi ce qu'il est
intelligent
jetair un accident un accident un
accident dans une force pas leader sur
la route de salies une cicatrice
une cicatrice là comme sylvie vartan
c'était une perversion
version
azo film il ya que moi qui ai parlé
zoophilie d'habitude pourquoi j'aime
tellement les animaux que abord cherche
à éviter de ses moyens il parle de ce
genre de bruit mais j'ai trouvé mon
maître alors
mais quel animal du père reste les
sharks gbagbo le seul film et c'est la
ride
petit jaguar à bord n'a rien de plus
beau pour essayer je sais pas mais si
j'étais vraiment une perversion avance
que ce serait telle la balle aussi pour
la jeu qui déteint d eau par exemple je
sais quoi
la tempérance la tempérance et étaient
une injure
une copie dans un taxi en avant par une
infirmité peu j'ai failli rester en
selle alors il ne paraît pas eu un grave
accident la vue de ce pc à 1 6 morceaux
sur la longueur et paula est à man ça va
aller bien terminer une guerre c'était
obligé les swingueurs celle des sacs
parce qu'elle est là abel a créé un vif
les chrétiens un dictateur
même qu'adam un supplice
un celui de la question tu vois tu t'en
sors pas mal so what
what i'm
[Musique]
c'est bien même johnny rotten pourtant
ça autant c'est un pote tu vois à bas
prix tu vois d'imphy même génie rothen
ne bouge pas pendant le jihad dans ta
révolution bien d'ailleurs si je sors
j'ai vu quelques images
une fille qui s'appelle pâte lamberti
qui me dit sa révolution coûte cher à
batteries ba oui il est toujours pas là
fred b qui donc veut faire son site sur
les gens qui veulent bouger des
bassistes puis à quelques opposants il
ya un mec s'appelle vincent vallières
qui a viré sa fiancée clair parce
qu'elle bougeait par le jingle et il y
en a d'autres comme mourad abbas qui dit
moi je ne bouge pas pendant génial parce
que toute façon je suis bien au chaud
sous la couette et alors oui il ya une
fille qui dit elle s'appelle floriane
elle dit si j'enlève un vêtement à
chaque jingle est-ce que je peux bouger
la réponse est oui dérogation spéciale
alors on va faire avec jenny rothen une
interview anti portrait chinois
daniel difficile à expliquer le portrait
chinois c'est si vous étiez une fleur
qu'est ce que vous seriez comme fleurs
je serai un mieux autisme lentilles
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
maladie donc johnny rotten if you were
10 is what kind of disease would you be
je serai là peste parce que je ressemble
à un rap par la peste
si vous étiez une injure suite une
injure ouais ça veut dire daniel ne sais
pas
le traducteur espèce de brigands bagnols
j'ai bien compris je ferai du porno très
bien gagner belinda tête plus rapidement
si vous étiez un accident je serai en
ambulance si vous étiez une guerre 3 et
pyongyang
si vous étiez un vice
amy fils si vous étiez un supplice je
pense que d'une certaine manière
musicalement je le suis c'est bien si
vous étiez une cicatrice score
cicatrices anales
un poison eisen à oman à la salmonelle
j'aime bien l'essentiel prenait le fut
mais je suis vous étiez un [ __ ] oui
beaucoup dirais que je suis déjà si vous
étiez un assassin j'aurais pas de
problème de gestion je pense si vous
étiez un virus quelque chose sur
internet
l avion à l'avenir je pense il
si vous étiez un dictateur à jeudi d'une
certaine manière visible un dictateur
espagnol parce que ça devient pire 17h02
bouche espagnol boutique espagnole
si vous étiez un terroriste mais je le
suis avec a demandé à la famille royale
al thani qui me connaissent très bien et
si vous étiez la mort quel genre de mort
seriez-vous ça c'est quelque chose que
je n'entends pas je suis sourd tout d'un
coup bravo
[Musique]
bien si vous étiez à défaut la curiosité
une dernière sion peut-être mon papa
souhaitiez une arme énorme l'écriture un
supplice
un supplice un interrogatoire comme
celui-là la wii zijin cicatrice à
nombril un poison
l'ennui c'est une [ __ ]
en dehors de moi je vois pas une panne
ou panne
une panne d'ascenseur complice gens
hystériques un dictateur ou vous si vous
étiez une infirmité voir la vie en rose
grâce à sa haine anti biotiques
souhaitiez une torture une plume
légitime d'humiliation peut-être une
page blanche et souhaité une mort une
mort ou rire quand je sauve la vie de
quelqu'un bravo en aluminium
[Musique]
la bouger bouger
je crois que c'est oui je sais catherine
mais je crois que c'est le prénom je
crois qu'on n'y peut rien si tu veux
c'est un truc de laurent vité jamais
alors faire l'anti portrait chinois
d'accord non alors par exemple donc de
vous dire si vous étiez une fleur vont
apprendre il ya un mieux autistes
simplement dit que je vais vous dire si
vous étiez un défaut un des shows wii ou
la vache un défaut j'hésite entre mais
jouer votre groupe c le jour si vous
étiez une injure
une injure wattez jour on croirait que
dans 10 une maladie une maladie d'amour
à un accident un accident les crottes de
mon chien que j'ai un chien qui joue ici
avant lui alors il s'appelle le chocolat
c'est ça non pas chocolat il est chaud
chocolat il s'appelle rebelles à bon
repos comme son père ah c'est pas moi
qui ai si vous étiez une perversion si
j'étais une perversion le ferait votre
questionnaire chez retire de la bonne
réponse une guerre une guerre
la prochaine ouais un vis à vis le sexe
laurent clés qu'on lui dit c'est que si
qu'on salisse c'est pas obligatoire non
trahison trahison une trahison
le seul qui m'a le plus marqué ces
dernières années c'est celle de nicolas
sarkozy et d'edouard balladur
voilà mais voilà oui effectivement ils
sont une arme si j'étais une arme je
serai humour un supplice un supplice
clémence arnaud non michel exagère pas
nous regarder le mardi soir mais il ya
tous les samedis 6 et une cicatrice une
cicatrice l'arrêt du cul c'est après si
vous étiez un poison le tabac une [ __ ]
linda hardy
[Applaudissements]
la connaissance et croiser ici y croise
et décroise une affaire labrador un
impôt un impôt sur les grandes fortunes
moi je suis pour oui moi je me suis
jamais plaint de payer des sommes
exactement les gens qui gagnent de
l'argent et de refuser toute chasse et
la cox une panne sexuelle
oui c'est la plus d'emmerdés jamais
l'emmener à votre à jamais mais je suis
tombé dans la marmite du viagra quand
j'étais petit le viagra c'est une petite
pilule bleue comme école sous la dent
exact l'acfo la m c'est des mecs ils bon
c'est bien sûr j'ai testé pour
l'événement du jeudi à l'epa oui c'est
vrai à l'événement du jeudi c'était le
nom du journal et vous allaitez qu'est
ce que le viagra par bruno masure jean
pierre coffe et laurent ruquier bon
voilà c'est alors ça vous fait rire
c'est bien sûr comme moi vous avez
[Musique]
si vous étiez une torture une torture
clémence à nos efforts soient
enseignants bennati que je vois si vous
étiez une humiliation une nuit dans le
bide
ah ouais le bibi rien de pire vous êtes
sur scène ou même à la radio ou à la
télé vous croyez dire un truc de route
et ses collants et rigole pas voilà ça
c'est une humiliation
1 je voudrais jamais si ça arrive il
avant tout le monde avant si vous étiez
mort la petite mort on ne bouge pas
pendant les diggers
[Musique]
si vous étiez une injure c'est pas une
injure celle de l'âge une perversion la
virginité bravo une guerre recèle des
sexes une trahison
ben je sais pas le dentiste qui me dit
toujours que ça peut faire mal
[Rires]
si vous étiez une arme l'humour un
supplice un supplice qu'on me demande de
me taire un poison et pokémon aa oui ok
mais si vous étiez une [ __ ] la mort un
dictateur mon chien qui va faire tous
les jours un microbe j'irais plutôt un
parasite genre acariens jour dans
l'élite agréable un terroriste a
terrorist l'image je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un terrorisme pour
moi les artistes les gens qui font ce
métier l'image est toujours comme il
faut plaire à qui on doit plaire une
espèce de dictature donc je trouve
extrêmement pénible et lourdes voilà une
torture une torture j'ai pas être
oubliée jacques vernier lancy s'empêcher
noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]